c'est dans cette cité habituellement
calme du marin que ces jouets le drame
hier soir peu avant minuit les pompiers
sont appelés en intervention dans cet
appartement de la résidence La Agnès
derrière la porte un homme de 53 ans en
arrêt cardio respiratoire et présentant
5 marques de coups de couteau au thorax
selon les voisins présents sur place
l'auteur des fesses le fils de la
victime et lorsque j'ai ouvert ma
fenêtre j'ai vu qu'il y avait les
gendarmes ça et puis ça allait demander
ce qui se passait c'est là que j'ai vu
qu'on est parti avec lui le monde était
à la maison on est parti avec son fils
et son fils on est allé chercher l'homme
il se passe ils ont trouvé et après on
est mauvais avec lui tout ça
dans le quartier la nouvelle a provoqué
de les mois le quinquagénaire était
visiblement apprécié du voisinage c'est
ma voisine qui est venue ce matin qui me
dit si j'ai entendu ce qui s'est passé
alors je lui ai dit non et puis me dire
oui le petit monsieur qui passe là tout
le temps qui est habitué son frère à
côté que son fils là tu veux seulement
monsieur qui est très très respectueux
qui a passé il y a de son frère kabeille
blague
mais là les différents
c'est le travail il était très
sympathique avec tout le monde a prioré
par les gendarmes peu de temps après les
faits l'auteur présumé un homme d'une
vingtaine d'années était entendu
aujourd'hui à la brigade du marin c'est
le 24e homicide en Martinique depuis le
début de l'année